hello everyone and welcome to another
parallel programming and super computing
tutorial video
in the last video you guys were shown
how you can use um
if statements with your parallel
programming or super computing and mpi
in this video i'm going to show you guys
one more command
and some simple math that it's going to
do by node based on this new simple
command
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so here's another blank document
and again we start with the same thing
so we're going to say from
mpi for pi import mpi
and then again com equals mpi.com
underscore world rank
equals com.rank so we're just going to
make some shorthand here
and now we're going to introduce a new
um
bit of information i suppose that's
gonna be size equals com.size and what
this is gonna return is how many nodes
are in the system
so later on you can use some conditional
formatting
um i keep saying conditional formatting
it's not really
it's like conditional setup i guess uh
based on how many nodes
are in your total network and then you
can can you can reference size so
instead of hard coding in like
you know we have 64 nodes node you know
1 4 9 and 12 do blah blah
or whatever you can just reference size
and split things up based on
size so you don't have to go through and
edit it
so anyways uh with that we're going to
just do some simple stuff we'll just say
print
rank and that's going to be rank
print node count
and that's going to be size
and then finally just for kicks we'll
print 9 to the power
of rank plus three
so we should see rank zero be nine to
the power of
three so like 729 i think
and then we'll see rank one be nine to
the power of 4 which is a number i don't
know
so save that and let's go ahead and move
this
however type it twice if you're typing
these i'm using scp
though okay so come over here
hit the up arrow and
okay sct 4
2 okay so we'll run it
and sure enough rank 0 node count total
obviously is two
729 which i got right thank you
i will take my cookie whoever wants to
give it rank one node count two
sixty five sixty one i'll give my cookie
to whoever knew what that was
so that's it so now you've been
introduced a
um new command which is size
which you can reference later on to do a
lot of a little bit more
um dynamic super computing
so that's going to conclude this uh
tutorial video nice short sweet
the next video what we're going to do is
i'll give you one more new
uh command and that's going to be how to
get the name of the
um the processor basically
and then also i'll show you guys how you
can send
and receive data so that's pretty
exciting so
hopefully you guys are excited for that
stay tuned to the next video as always
thanks for watching